nous avons découvert quelque chose
d'incroyable maroc et mon équipe a été
autorisée à commencer il faut
c'est dans ce que tu vas vivre et le
maroc ce c'est magnifique tu vas adorer
tu as tu m'emmènes l école aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui et tous les autres genres
oratoire dollar si jamais tu as besoin
de moi ici je planterai tout court
et je reviendrai très narines
qu'est-ce qui se passe
tellement vrai désolé mais je nourrisse
nouvelle honte
capital paxton c'est un honneur de vous
rendre une sommes d'accord sur le fait
qu'il est par deux questions
d'innovation d'une mission de sauvetage
une fois localisés on pourra les
extraire
l'américaine sera exécuté samedi soir
après la prière si la rançon n'est pas
payé
il doit bien que j'aime ma femme plus
que tout au monde voit tout ce qui sera
nécessaire
ouvert du reste bien à la vue et ramé
keita de maison elle avait tu commences
younès
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle
[Musique]
roy présidente
les ambassadeurs ou sache pas certaine
[Musique]
chose